المجلس الاطلسي في واشنطن اصدر تقريرا
بعنوان اهم 23 خطرا وفرصه للعام 2023
التقرير تحدث عن احتمال ابتعاد عده دول
منها حلفاء وخصوم للولايات المتحده عن
الدولار تقليص هذه الدول اعتمادها على
الدولار سيكون بشكل اسرع مما كان متوقعا
بحسب التقرير
العقوبات غير المسبوقه على روسيا بسبب حرب
اوكرانيا زادت احتماليه الابتعاد السريع
عن الدولار عمليا ما تزال مزايا الدولار
متجذره بعمق في النظام المالي العالمي لكن
التحول يحدث تدريجيا وحصه الدولار من
احتياطيات النقد الاجنبي اخده في الانخفاض
عده دول بدات تستثمر في التقنيات مثل
العملات الرقميه لتقليل الاعتماد على
الدولار منها الصين والهند واندونيسيا
وماليزيا وجنوب افريقيا